you've heard of zmap this is the
experimental treatment that helped two
Americans recover from Ebola this isn't
a clinical result but zmap might work
and because of that the government is
throwing money at map biopharmaceuticals
this is the company that makes zmap what
you don't know is the federal government
has been throwing money at the idea
behind zmap since 2007 so why don't we
have a stockpile the problem is that the
government is very good at paying for
research but it's not very good at
paying for that research to become an
approved therapy or vaccine but the
government is the only entity that can
do this take an idea and turn it into an
approved treatment there's no market for
treatments for hemorrhagic fevers like
Ebola or marberg it's not like Viagra or
lipor nobody needs this stuff until all
a sudden everybody needs it in February
of 2011 the defense threat reduction
agency that's a part of the Pentagon
wanted to make a commitment to take zmap
and move it towards a license therapy
but a commitment is not money it's just
a promise to go through the Contracting
process to try and get money in the
future in some parts of the federal
government the Contracting process can
take 6 months this is true at the NIH
for example in the Pentagon it takes a
little longer with IND ditra it took 2
years February 2011 to February 2013
just to get a check written to Matt
biopharmaceutical so that's potentially
18 months of research time what did we
lose it's possible that with that money
zmap could have moved forward through a
series of clinical trials that would
have qualified it for what the FDA
referred to as emergency use
authorization this isn't enough for
commercial use but it is enough for the
CDC and the Pentagon to start building
up an emergency stockpile so it's
possible that we don't have a stockpile
of zmap a therapy that may work against
Ebola for the simplest of reasons the
federal government does not know how to
write a
check